i pour le groupe l'est républicain la
parole est à madame marie jo zimmermann
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer une
augmentation supplémentaire de 3,5
centimes par litre de taxes sur le
gasoil et de deux centimes sur le super
sans plomb 95
or ces mesures sont en contradiction
avec des engagements qui avaient été
pris en ait un effet début octobre le
gouvernement promettait une baisse de la
fiscalité d'un centimes pour l'essence
et une hausse limitée à 1 centimes pour
le diesel
cette augmentation de la fiscalité va
une nouvelle fois peser sur les ménages
est amputé leur pouvoir d'achat
de plus elle ne prend pas en compte une
hausse probable du prix du pétrole
compte tenu de l'instabilité de la
conjoncture géopolitique
enfin cette hausse va à l'encontre des
investissements massifs en recherche et
en développement des grands groupes
automobiles français
or c'est en accord avec les pouvoirs
publics que ceux ci ont fait le choix
d'un diesel propre répondant
parfaitement aux normes de pollution
cette annonce de plus survient sans
aucune concertation
en effet la mission parlementaire
d'information sur l'offre automobile
française dans une approche industrielle
énergétique et fiscale et dont je suis
membre aurait pu apporter au
gouvernement son expertise sur ce
dossier
monsieur le premier ministre la plus
grande usine de moteurs diesel au monde
se trouve dans ma circonscription à
trémery et des milliers de salariés sont
enquis inquiets pour leur emploi
je les comprends d'autant plus que les
décisions gouvernementales ne font pas
la différence entre les anciens moteurs
diesel effectué mme effectivement très
très polluants et la nouvelle génération
qui rejette moins de gaz à effet de
serre que les moteurs à essence
monsieur le premier ministre en plus
d'une nouvelle fiscalité des ménages
ne pensez-vous pas que cette croisade
anti diesel risque de porter un coup
très grave à l'industrie automobile
française avec des impacts très très
lourd sur l'emploi
merci merci la parole est à mme et au
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
madame la présidente peine à messieurs
les députés madame la députée marie jo
zimmermann
beaucoup d'éléments dans votre question
mais une affirmation simple c'est que le
signal est donné d'une évolution de nos
pratiques en matière de carburant ce
signal est donné pour trois raisons la
première c'est qu'il nous faut lutter
contre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et le réchauffement climatique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
majorité a mis en place une contribution
climat énergie
vous le saviez vous avez échoué à mettre
en place le prix du carbone tout le
monde se réjouit au bourget qu'on fixe
le prix du carbone la france l'a fait et
la france l'assument et vous saviez que
la contribution climat énergie
augmenterait a été fixé depuis deux ans
son évolution avait été fixé la deuxième
raison c'est la protection de la qualité
de l'air un certain nombre d'études faut
toujours garder de l'humilité par
rapport à toutes les études mais ce
nombre d'études montrent qu'il y à des
émissions de microparticules et que nous
devons avancer vers la convergence entre
la fiscalité le prix du gazole et le
prix de l'essence est la troisième
raison c'est la nécessité d'utiliser au
mieux les biocarburants c'est un autre
mouvement certes modeste sur la
fiscalité mais votre attachement madame
la députée à l'usiné de trémery commun
celle de metz que je partage pour
connaître bien cette région n'interdit
pas de donner un signal effectivement à
l'ensemble de nos industriels qui ont
toujours su s'adapter
nous prenons un virage mais ce n'est pas
forcément un virage serré
c'est une convergence de la fiscalité
qui est étalée dans le temps
+ 1 - 1 cette année + 1 - 1 l'an
prochain le premier ministre l'a annoncé
cela donne le temps cela donne le temps
à notre industrie performante en matière
de fabrication de moteurs le temps de
s'adapter
c'est ce qu'elle a toujours su faire 9
août